so i have an interesting system over
here i have two compartments on the left
compartment i have a gas that is at a
temperature of t sub a and on the right
side of this i have gas that has a
temperature of t sub b
and they are separated by a wall of
depth d or i guess you say a thickness d
and the contact area between of the wall
or the contact area of the gas onto the
wall that area is a and i'm just drawing
a section of it we're assuming that
these two compartments are completely
separated now what i'm curious about and
we're going to assume that the
temperature on the left is higher than
the temperature on the right and so
because of that you're going to have a
transfer of thermal energy from the left
to the right and that that thermal
energy that gets transferred we call
that heat and we'll denote that with the
letter q i'm curious about how does the
rate at which heat is transferred or so
how much heat is transferred per unit
time that's the rate at which heat is
transferred how would that change
depending on how we change these
different variables so for example if
our
if our area if our contact area were to
go up what would that do for q over t
well then q over t would also increase
per unit time because i have that i have
more area for these hot molec these hot
air particles or hot air molecules to
bump into and they'll heat that wall and
then there'll be more heated wall to
heat up the colder air particles so in
that case
our rate of heat transfer would also go
up well what if we
what if we and obviously if i made my
area smaller maybe i should just write
that explicitly if i made my contact
area smaller then my rate of heat
transfer my rate of heat transfer would
go down and that feels like common sense
now what about
what about the thickness if i were to
make it if i were to make
the thickness larger if i were to make
this a thicker wall what would that do
to my rate of heat transfer
well then i would have i would have more
things that i would have to heat up to
get it to a certain temperature to
before i can or
which then can heat up the particles on
the right and obviously this is a
continuous process it'll always be
happening but there'll just be more
stuff to heat up and it's going to take
longer and more of that and more of that
more of that kinetic energy that average
kinetic energy is going to get
dissipated in this wall so if this wall
becomes thicker if the wall becomes
thicker then the rate of heat transfer
is going to go down or if you could if
the wall became thinner if this depth
decreased then the rate of heat transfer
then the rate of heat transfer would go
up so you could say the rate of heat
transfer is going to be inversely
proportional to the thickness of this
wall
now what else could we think about well
we could think about the temperature
differential
the temperature differential that's t
sub a
minus
minus t sub b
minus t sub e well if this temperature
differential
if this temperature differential were to
go up well what's going to happen
well it's common sense that what this is
super hot if this is super hot over here
this is way hotter than what we have on
the right well we're going to have more
heat transferred so the rate of heat
transfer you have more heat transfer per
unit time your rate of heat transfer is
going to go up and likewise if this if
this differential were to go down and
you could take the extreme case if there
was no differential if t sub a was the
same as t sub b
then you would have no net heat transfer
frankly in any unit of time so it makes
sense that the rate of heat transfer is
going to be proportional to the
temperature differential
so how can we encapsulate all of this
intuition into maybe a formula for
describing thermal conductivity for the
for for for thinking about how quickly
some how quickly this heat will be
transferred the rate of heat transfer
well we could say the read the rate of
heat transfer and this is really
hopefully you know comes out of a little
bit of common sense or an intuition of
what would happen here the rate of heat
transfer i could say it's going to be
proportional to well what are the things
that's going to be proportional to it's
going to be proportional to the area the
more surface area we have on this wall
more contact area
the more heat we're going to have
transferred per unit time so it's going
to be proportional to
that contact area it's also going to be
proportional to the temperature
differential so let's multiply this
times the temperature differential
so t sub a
minus t sub b
minus t sub b and it's inversely
proportional to the thickness of the
wall
so all of that
over the thickness of the wall
and now another thing that you might be
saying okay i have this proportionality
constant but wouldn't this be different
for different materials for example if
this was a metal wall wouldn't this
conduct the heat quicker than if this
was a wood wall and you would be correct
a metal wall would and so this k this k
right over here this is dependent this
is dependent on the material so what is
the wall made of so material
material
of
of the wall and you can actually you can
actually measure this thing and
different different materials will have
different thermal conductivities which
this which this variable right over here
would actually represent so going
through a little bit of intuition we
were able to come up with what looks
like a a fancy formula and you will
sometimes see this formula formula for
thermal conductivity through a solid
barrier but it really comes out of
hopefully common sense the rate of the
amount of heat transferred per time is
going to be proportional to and the
proportionality constants can be
dependent on the material styrofoam for
example would be very low here that's
why coolers are made out of styrofoam
and it's going to be dependent on the
area it's going to be proportional to
the area the temperature differential
and then inversely proportional to the
thickness so if you wanted to really
insulate something you would want to
minimize surface area
and and you would want to and you would
want to maximize the thickness and you
would want to have something with a very
low thermal conductivity so a thick
styrofoam
wall that's maybe shaped in a sphere
might be a pretty good container for for
keeping something hot or for keeping
something cool